Yeah.
So,
so,
okay,
so there is something we could talk
about for a minute because you know,
there's,
uh,
there's political,
what do you call rumblings about the
fact that I think a lot of this is
generated by the radical left types,
particularly on the campuses,
but the system is rigged and that
it's an oppressive patriarchy.
And that the reason that people are at
the top is because they played power
games.
And you know,
it's this,
my sense is that the
control is that we're,
we're ethnic or racial or gender groups
and we're competing in the Marxists
manner and those who win have
one because of oppression.
But I know the literature on the
relationship between individuals,
individual differences and longterm life
success in the Western world and the
literature is actually very clear.
So intelligence seems to account for
about 20% of the variants in longterm life
success.
And then trait conscientiousness
accounts for perhaps another,
maybe 10 to 15%.
And then there's smaller
contributions of emotional stability,
um,
and also have trait openness,
which seems to be a good predictor
of entrepreneurial ability.
So it looks like in the West that you
can attribute about 40 to 50% of the
variants.
Maybe that's a little high,
but it's,
it's not,
it's not a radical over estimate to the
sorts of individual differences that are
associated with productivity because
increases in Iq hierarchy you at higher
conscientiousness definitely
make people more productive.
It seems to me that you can
use that as an index of the,
um,
of the,
of the genuinely meritocratic nature of
a culture and also as an index of its
willingness to engage in fair
play because you'd expect if it,
if your culture is aimed at productivity
and it turns out that those are the
most PR and it turns out that the
most productive people are in fact
differentially rewarded.
That seems to me to be a reasonable
index of the success of this society now
that that is still leaves 50 to
60% of the variance on explained.
And so you can,
in there you could include racism and
prejudice and the tyranny of the system
and blind luck can physical health and
all of the arbitrary and random events
that make up that determined whether
someone is successful or fails in life.
But it does seem to me to provide a
metric saying that not only is our society
crazily productive and reasonably and
reasonably good at district distributing
the spoils,
even though there's still some inequality,
but a fair bit of inequality is
actually generated as a consequence of
differences in genuine productivity
that seem reasonable to you.
Yeah,
maybe it ought to be obvious and,
but now,
except for the fact that in
a lot of intellectual life,
the assumption is that the correlation
between a psychological traits and
success is zero.
So the fact that it's,
you know,
let's say it's 40%,
I think it says 33% I bet a lot higher
than in most people are willing to
acknowledge.
And what you said is exactly right.
That leaves more than half of the
variance not to be correlating that with
individual differences.
And of course,
uh,
various inequities could go into that,
that got 50 or 60%.
And uh,
there's no,
they're not mutually
I,
it seems hard.
Uh,
we,
we know that there's a lot of gaming
of the system particularly yeah.
United States by,
by the wealthy.
Uh,
and that should obviously be eliminated.
It's not,
not fair.
It's not.
If we could also ask another question
is whether the rewards that go to the
talented are necessarily in sectors
that lead to what we might call a
productivity in the sense of,
of,
um,
increasing societal wealth.
And an argument can be made that there's
some misallocation of intellectual
resources that we have,
uh,
that the,
economy,
uh,
is,
to,
to driven by,
by finance that the,
uh,
there are too many lawsuits.
Legal system is each other.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
our estimated by intellectuals,
this does still leave a,
a,
a place for criticizing a number of the,
uh,
the reason which our economy is set up.
There's always scope for improvement.
Yes.
And we were talking about why despite
the fact that a fair bit of the variance
or a third to half of the variance in,
in life success is taken up by let's say,
individual attributes,
there's still room for a
systemic critique that's valid.
Yeah.
One of the pathologies of intellectual
life that I wrote about it in the blank
slate about denial of
human nature was that,
uh,
the in,
in polite company and
the intellectual circles,
the amount of light success determined
by a inherent and largely heritable
psychological traits has to be zero.
I mean that just the,
the,
the only acceptable position.
And you,
and I know it's not zero.
Well,
so let me interject for one second.
I'm also,
there's a fairness element there.
But the other thing is,
it seems to me that that's extraordinary
self serving of people too.
Because you know,
if you get together with a
group of Harvard professors,
for example,
um,
it's pretty obvious that their innate
intelligence is one of the factors that
determine their success.
And to deny the fact that
heritable differences make
a difference means perhaps
to act as an Avatar of a
social justice orientation,
but equally to deny the role of,
of the benefits of Champs in
your own success and to their,
for lack a certain degree of humility
that you might otherwise be required to
have.
So it's not all,
and I'm not claiming that you
were implying this at all,
but it's not all in the service of higher
social ideals that people denied they,
the contribution of,
of heritable components,
for example,
the birth laundry.
So,
okay.
Okay.
Whoops.
We just,
okay.
I unfortunately the video
just froze and after you said,
I'm not saying you claimed this,
uh,
you suddenly froze on the screen.
We're not saying you're claiming this.
Sure.
Well,
it's just,
it seems self serving for people
who are particularly bright,
for example,
to not be grateful for the fact that
they won the genetic lottery in that in
that manner and insufficiently humble,
um,
to not know what the role
of that arbitrary chance in
determining their success.
I mean it's not like they don't
deserve their success because of that,
but claiming a certain degree
of biological determinism,
it doesn't necessarily make you a bad
person even though it can be read that way
because it makes you very sensitive
to your own good fortune if you,
if you think it through carefully.
Oh absolutely.
In fact,
successful people are the winners
of at least three lotteries.
One of them that you mentioned,
of course it's the
genetic lottery lottery.
The fact that does that some people
were born with greater intelligence and
conscientiousness and
openness to experience.
Another is that there's a a second
lottery in a human development that is not
strictly genetic,
but it is in a sense
constitutional or developmental.
The fact that I might consider this one
of the most profound discoveries in the
history of psychology,
that correlation is between
identical twins reared together,
are generally on the order of 0.5.
Uh,
and they share not only their genome,
but,
uh,
the vast amount of their
environments that their parents,
their neighborhoods,
they're older sibs.
They're younger sibs,
the number of books in the house,
number of guns in the house,
number of TVs in the house,
yet they're not indistinguishable.
A identical twins are a
correlate quite highly,
but no one near perfectly,
which means that there is a second lottery
that has to do either with just the
way the,
the brain,
uh,
congeals during development,
which can't be specified down to
the last synapse by the genes.
Uh,
and perhaps by chance life events,
which might leave unpredictable traces
that we can't add a documenter or
systematically understand.
And then of course,
there's the third lottery of,
uh,
what happens to you in your profession.
Did you bet on the right sector?
Did you happen to have a good
relationship with the boss?
Numerous.
Right?
It's a matter of being in the
right place at the right time,
the right time.
So all that having been said,
um,
and,
and you're,
you're absolutely right.
We have to acknowledge
the none zero role of,
uh,
of hereditary can permit and
talent the one zero role of chance.
And that still leaves a big chunk of the
variance that could be due to systemic
features of the system that
perhaps ought to be changed.
There's just no doubt
that the wealthy game,
the system,
particularly in the United States in
a number of ways that don't work to,
to the,
the benefit of society at large.
There are also aspects of the system
that are perhaps fair but irrational.
The fact that so much of our intellectual
talent now gets sucked into finance.
Now of course we do need a financial
sector and it's good that they're smart
people in it,
but having a lot of our brain power
devoted to figuring out how to act on
financial information,
it Microsoft microsecond faster than
ones competitors is probably not the best
use of our society's intellectual capital.
Likewise,
a lot of,
there's no doubt that we have far
too much brain power invested in,
in the the legal system in a
corporation suing each other,
patent trolling and another
not so productive uses.
Yeah.
Well the funny thing is too,
there's an,
there's a new routing in erotic
or amount of pathology in,
in a system in some sense.
I mean one of the things that struck me
quite hard for example is that if you
look at the creativity
curves across the lifespan,
they matched the criminality
curves almost perfectly.
And one of the things that made me think
when I was doing that research was so
that as young men become more antisocial,
they also become more creative.
Even though those things
might not be correlated,
but they do map on top of one another
and we're sticking in a society like the
United States,
which has a fair degree of criminality
but also a fair degree of creativity.
We have no idea how loose the system has
to be so that malfeasance can thrive so
that it can also be simultaneously loose
enough so that creativity can thrive.
Right.
Because you might think if you were
optimistic that you can tighten up the
system and get rid of the
criminal behavior without
adding a totalitarian layer
to this system that would
also simultaneously demolish,
you know,
individual variability and creativity.
We just,
our models just aren't sophisticated
enough to tease such things apart,
you know.
Well,
they,
I,
I'm not so sure there.
I do agree with you that
there's a certain amount of,
uh,
risk taking or young men on the bake
that might underlie both criminality and,
uh,
productive creativity.
But,
uh,
over the course of history,
I think one of the accomplishments
of civilization and indeed of,
uh,
of enlightenment driven progress is that
we have managed to tease them apart.
Just two examples are the fact that the
rate of homicide punished by a factor of
about 35 from the Middle Ages
to the 20th century and that,
and that includes the
scientific revolution,
the Industrial Revolution,
and the enlightenment to all of
the events of the 20th century.
So justice people were
not stabbing each other.
So if we're in salts,
they were also coming up with the theory
of evolution than the atomic theory of
matter.
And then again,
the 1990s when the rate of violent
crime in the United States fell by half,
and they were also declines in Canada,
Britain,
other western countries.
This certainly was not a time
of economic stagnation or tech.
No,
no.
Fair enough.
I guess then the question starts to become
is how in the world did those things
get teased apart so that we are able to
regulate anti social behavior without
simultaneously making things,
um,
excessively rigid,
unregulated totalitarian.
We managed it.
Maybe it's part of that same incremental
process that you detailed out at the
beginning of our talk.